hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new pixel 4a and today we're
comparing it to
the iphone se and we're not only going
to be comparing your typical things such
as performance and giving you my honest
first impressions
of the device but we're also going to
compare things like the display quality
and the brightness
speakers and other things that most
people don't cover
it's been a while since we've done a
phone video so hit that thumbs up button
if you guys enjoy it and make sure to
stay to the end
where i'll let you know if you should
buy one of these let's go ahead and get
right into it i'm going to open this
up and it's interesting that this year
google actually just kept it very simple
we no longer have a larger
option you just have one model six gigs
of ram
128 gigs of storage which is actually
quite nice for a phone
that costs 350 dollars sorry getting it
out here
i like that texture it doesn't feel
super high quality but it's
almost like a fake leather it's not
textured but it has this little mat
slightly rubbery but also plasticy feel
not too bad
let's peel that off there okay that
feels
nice in the hand it's very interesting
the iphone definitely feels
more premium all glass we have the
aluminum on the sides
this feels like an expensive device
where this feels kind of
cheap but not sucky really the buttons
feel nice really nice and clicky
and it feels lighter even though if you
guys look over here
it's actually slightly larger looks like
it's
about the same width maybe slightly
wider slightly taller
but it does feel lighter as well i had
to get the previous pixel 3a this the xl
model just to compare
it definitely feels cheaper this year
than the previous year i like this
two-tone design i kind of wish
they stuck with that now this camera
bump is updated it's larger just like a
lot of newer cameras even though it's a
single one over here
compared to the sc's smaller one both
look fine
and one thing you guys might notice at
the top here is that the pixel 4a
has a headphone jack which is a plus in
my book
of course our chargers are different
lightning versus usb
type-c and the pixel does win out
because it
includes an 18 watt fast charger in the
box the iphone supports it
but you're gonna have to spend another
30 to 40 bucks for the charger and the
cable
if you want to have fast charging that
definitely is a bummer now along with
that the battery in the pixel 4a
is close to twice as large as the one in
the iphone sc
but that doesn't mean you're gonna get
double the battery life in real world
you'll probably get about one to two
hours of extra screen on time depending
on what you're doing
but that is still fairly significant now
as we're setting up the pixel 4a let's
talk about the displays you guys can
right away see a big difference
the iphone is still using the iphone 8
design we have this large forehead
this large chin with our touch id sensor
whereas the pixel 4a has a modern design
the screen fills up most of the front we
have this little cutout for the
front-facing camera on the left-hand
side
the pixel definitely looks a lot better
now not only that
it's also using the oled display instead
of using an lcd
and instead of being slightly higher
than 720p on the iphone
this is actually slightly higher than
1080p now before i compare the screen
brightness detail and speakers
let me mention the fingerprint readers
as i showed you guys we have one on the
back like with most pixels
and i do prefer that instead of having
touch id up front just because
that's exactly where my hands kind of
lay my fingers just right there when i
pick it up i don't have to shift down to
touch
let's go ahead and set this thing up and
we'll do a little speed test as you
probably know touch id is very fast
it works very well but the pixel 4 seems
to be just as fast as soon as i put my
finger on the sensor
even if the screen's off it opens up
let's finish off our display comparison
as you guys can see the pixel 4 a's
display is larger
everything on screen is a little bit
larger and i see more info at the bottom
which is
nice as far as actual sharpness from
normal viewing distances
even though this has a lot more pixels i
can't really tell a difference
the text is sharp everything looks nice
on the screen
only when i get about this close can i
tell that the text is smoother on the
pixel 4a
now one other thing that i noticed is
that the display has less reflections
than the iphone display
and that is surprising typically most
android phones have more reflection
so that is a plus and on top of that
viewing angles are also
better the brightness stays better the
contrast stays better if you're looking
off axis
and now let's test the maximum
brightness and displays both are set to
manual right now
and on some of these lower end oled
displays they can't get that bright
so here we have them both actually put
out a decent uh
output but it looks like the iphone is a
little bit brighter
and now it's time for our speaker
comparison make sure you get your best
pair of headphones so both phones have
dual speakers one up top
and one down firing let's go ahead and
start out with the pixel
[Music]
go ahead and let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below i'll
give you guys my opinion because we are
recording this with the mic and even
though it's a high quality one
this is going online the iphone se
did sound better the highs were a lot
more crisp we had a little bit more
bass but it was quieter overall the
pixel is louder and not only that the
pixel is also
more balanced which is something you
probably can't hear with um if you're
listening through youtube
the iphone this is a iphone 8 design so
the bottom firing speaker is louder it
doesn't sound balanced where the pixel
is
balanced and overall if you guys see
this clip over here the pixel is going
to give you a much
better movie viewing experience look how
much larger the screen is we have an ola
display for better blacks
you just really can't compare and now
let's talk about performance
unfortunately geekbench 5 won't even
download on the pixel 4a
maybe it's just the operating system is
too new or something like that so we are
going to be using
antutu of course the iphone sc has the
um a13 bionic processor top of the line
it's going to be more powerful but let's
just see how much more powerful
is it as you guys could tell with this
graphics benchmark that we start out
with
the iphone is playing back perfectly
smoothly whereas the pixel is
choppy the graphics chip is definitely
weaker and of course the screen is
larger resolution
now while this runs runs let me talk
about ram
the pixel 4a surprisingly has six
gigabytes of ram which is great for the
price
whereas the iphone has three but it
probably has better optimization
and then along with that with storage
the iphone has 64 gigs
of storage compared to double 128
with the pixel 4a which is also really
good all right our results are in
and overall the iphone se is a little
bit over
60 percent faster now let's take a look
at the breakdown here
as far as the cpu score um it's actually
not
that huge of a difference not as big of
a difference as i expected
now with graphics you guys saw that
difference when we were doing
the graphics test the iphone series
graphics are more than twice
as powerful which is a massive
difference uh i wish the graphics were
faster on the pixel 4. and it's using
the snapdragon
730 with the g version for gaming but
it's not very good now with that said if
you're a gamer i wouldn't buy
the iphone se i would want to at least
get the 11
for the larger better screen now going
down to memory the iphone's memory is
also faster even though it only has half
the memory
and as far as the ui smoothness it is
also smoother as well
now with that said with my experience
when we're moving around
everything seems to be nice and fluid
i'm not getting any slowdowns or
anything like that and that's probably
possibly cpu-based i'm not sure but it
doesn't feel like a slow device of
course the iphone is nice and smooth
and it's going to stay smooth for a very
long time and now
let's talk about cameras both of these
have a single 12 megapixel
camera on the back even though the
camera bump is much
larger on the pixel and then on the
front the pixel has an eight megapixel
camera sensor compared to seven now i'm
going to take a couple of photos for you
guys and you guys
take a look at the selfie right here let
me know which one looks better
and then i also have this rear camera
shot and you guys let me know what you
think
i have to say that i like how much wider
the front-facing camera is on the pixel
4e that's a pretty big difference that
helps if you want to take selfies
with other people now as far as the
rear photo the pixel 4a is actually a
little bit more detailed if we punch
in which looks nice now when we go to
take a portrait shot the pixel actually
crops in two times to give you
a photo that is more similar to a
telephoto lens
compared to the iphone which stays
really wide as you guys can see the
difference is big
and with the iphone i can get up closer
to take a portrait shot
but then of course we do get some
distortion it's more pleasing on the
pixel
and from that far distance the iphone
actually wouldn't let me take a portrait
shot it wanted me to get closer
now the pixel's portrait photo is more
pleasing but it is a bummer that we have
to have that two times crop
because that means that for wider shots
it makes it
impossible to get both of these can also
take portrait shots with the front
facing camera
but the pixel is the only one that could
take portrait shots of
objects the iphone will only let you
take photos of people
now we're also going to do a deep dive
comparison as far as the photo quality
it's
actually going to be a blind one where
i'm going to take the photos and maybe
vadim will look
without knowing and give an unbiased
opinion as to which one is better but
overall the pixel does seem to be more
flexible with what it offers for photos
but we do have
another story for video now for front
facing video both these are 1080p
30 frames per second maximum but when we
switch over
to the rear cameras the iphone can
actually do 4k
at 60 frames per second instead of only
4k
30 so that definitely is a bummer now
let's go ahead and test out the
microphone quality
this is the front facing video quality
and the microphone quality
of the iphone se this is the
front-facing video quality and the
microphone quality on the google pixel
4a
make sure you guys have those
notifications enabled and you're
subscribed so you guys don't miss out on
our blind camera comparison
those are always so much fun to do to
film you guys really enjoy watching them
so you don't want to miss it
so we just compared a ton of things
about these phones
let me give you my honest opinion if
you're somebody
that is not stuck in apple's ecosystem
you don't have to have ios and if you're
trying to decide between these
most likely you're not stuck and you
only keep your phone for say one to two
years and you end up upgrading
i would go with the pixel 4a not only is
it 50
less expensive it also comes with a fast
charger which is another
30 to 40 value and along with that you
get double the ram
which we're not sure how much that helps
overall how that compares but you also
get double the storage which is really
nice
you get a headphone jack you get a nicer
display it's oled
the speakers are louder the camera
quality might be better
that's just a lot of value for 350
dollars and google is making
the right choice pricing it here and
giving us all these features
now if you're somebody that keeps your
phone long term i'm talking about three
four maybe even five years i would go
with the iphone
unfortunately it is stuck with the old
design but it's a low price point to get
into the apple ecosystem
and you know that it's gonna have
software updates for years and years to
come most likely five years or maybe
more
it's going to perform great and it's not
going to let you down
of course some of the stuff is older but
you know that is what it is maybe spend
some extra money on the iphone 11 which
is another
great option so there you guys have it
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below
definitely make sure you subscribe so
you guys can check out the upcoming
comparisons we have
with these phones and our review if you
guys have not yet picked up one of these
awesome comfortable
premium max tech modern apple products
shirts
i would go check it out this one
especially the premium one is really
nice
and you guys can help support the
channel and we're not biased even though
we have the shirt on the right video
we just said we'd get the pixel whatever
product is better is which the one we're
gonna recommend so thank you guys for
watching this one max
and i will see you in the next video
you